the Belgian city of Antwerp is the
world's oldest Diamond Trading Hub most
of the world's diamonds pass through it
a quarter of them are from Russia mined
by Al Rossa a company that's part owned
by the Kremlin with links to the Russian
military
there is actually a Russian military
submarine which has the name Al Rosa
which is a patron by orosa sponsored by
Arosa so this this is just one example
maybe the clearest example of direct
links between the military apparatus and
indeed the company
and tob's trade with Al Rosso was
condemned by the Ukrainian president in
a speech he gave to Belgium's Parliament
earlier this year
there are some that think that Russian
diamonds saw the network are more
important than our fights the EU is
rolling out another round of sanctions
against Moscow but once again Russian
Diamond Imports aren't part of it some
say that Belgium has quietly lobbied to
protect its multi-billion dollar
industry despite growing pressure within
Belgium and the block to stop the trade
I think it is important that we also
sanction diamonds or al-rosa and it's
yours the diamonds coming from Russia
they have blood on these diamonds
because the the revenues are used
directly or indirectly to support the
war on Ukraine the Prime Minister of
Belgium says that the country would not
block EU sanctions on the import of
Russian diamonds but that such a baron
could potentially hurt Europe more than
it could hurt Russia the spokesperson
for antwerp's Diamond industry says
sanctions would mean job losses and the
trade moving away from Belgium to places
where ethical standards are lower India
or Dubai had also the two other main
trading hubs that that do not follow
sanctions or that have no sanctions then
keep their trading relations as usual
with with Russia
Hyman's highlights the challenge faced
by the EU as it tries to increase
pressure on Moscow while seeking to
protect the needs of its citizens a
delicate balance that's not always
clear-cut Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
Antwerp Belgium